figure we got one more guy to try he's a
he's a lot of animals so let's see we
can do egg he takes me to the biggest
most aggressive wolf here he's over a
hundred pounds that is a big male this
Wolf's lost its natural fear of humans
because it was hand raised at another
facility when it arrived at the center
it wouldn't allow anyone close in even
attack Peng but still the animal must be
cared for so Peggy and her staff are
trying a new strategy they gang up like
a pack to assert their dominance
that's him yeah he's trash-talking
already talking smack
be very careful all right so I suggest
what we do you guys have sweep down this
side and push him okay we'll take him
either that corner or that corner to get
it to bite the bar we have to corner it
and cornered animals are always
dangerous encounters that's intimidating
that's right
he's big the closer we get the bigger
the wolf looks
like the hair standing up nice back stay
right where you are
go ahead and give him something bite on
406 pounds okay
that was kind of a defensive bite and
that's one hell of a defensive bite over
400 pounds that's the highest bite force
I've ever recorded from a canine more
force than its cousins Africa's wild
dogs that came in at 317 pounds and the
domestic dog at 328 rocky okay okay okay
okay come on
wolves better pack a lot more bark in
their bite than their canine
counterparts but they can't compete with
the fight there's any giant croc part of
the reason maybe too unlike Crocs adult
wolves have one set of teeth for liar
they have to be very careful not to
damage them biting too hard one way to
do that is by relying on the combined
bite strength of the pack
you